you are someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with head and neck cancer
this video will help you understand more
about this type of cancer and how it
affects the body
cancer of the head and neck may develop
in certain areas such as your sinuses
which are Hollow spaces in the bones of
your head around your nose
your nasal cavity
your mouth also known as your oral
cavity
your throat also known as your pharynx
your voice box also known as your larynx
and your salivary glands which are
organs that help you digest food
the cells lining most of these
structures are called squamous cells
the most common type of head and neck
cancer called squamous cell carcinoma
begins in these cells here normal cells
change into abnormal cells called cancer
cells over time these cells can grow out
of control and form a cluster called a
tumor
these tumors can grow and spread
destroying healthy tissue
symptoms for head and neck cancer vary
depending on the location of the cancer
in general symptoms may include a sore
that doesn't heal a lump that doesn't go
away a sore throat that doesn't go away
pain or trouble swallowing ear pain
hoarseness or change in your voice and
trouble breathing
other health problems may cause these
symptoms it's important to see your
doctor to be sure
if you have head and neck cancer your
doctor will try to find out the extent
of the disease and if it has spread this
is called staging the stages of cancer
range from zero to four a lower stage
means less cancer growth a higher stage
means more cancer growth
the two main risk factors for head and
neck cancer are alcohol and tobacco use
including smokeless tobacco other risk
factors include infection with certain
viruses such as human papillomavirus or
Epstein-Barr virus
exposure to certain workplace substances
and past radiation therapy of the head
and neck
if you are dealing with a diagnosis of
head and neck cancer continue to talk to
your doctor and your Cancer Care team